boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
very excited to continue being doing
interviews at qoph as the Congress on
the future of engineering software for
our second annual partnership with them
we are now speaking with Pete wells
hello hello things are coming onto the
show really appreciate it thanks for
having me very excited to chat Pete
along with a ton of other things he's on
the board of directors at coefficients
two for the last two and a half years
he's also for the last 17 and a half
years is the president and CEO of smart
to market and prior to that eighteen and
a half years at HP doing regional sales
manager and he's also for 20 23 years as
a volunteer firefighter which is so cool
that you were saying earlier completed
from part of of neurocircuitry and this
is so interesting to be able to smash
together things like different life
essences together into into some to you
what is your life now Pete let's talk
about this so your journey you know how
did you pick up your interests as a kid
and start molding into who you are today
yeah good question and and you know a
lot of it comes down to I think
curiosity as a small child I probably
got in trouble more than not for taking
things apart and not being able to put
it back together again I always wanted
to help things worked and I think that
curiosity drove me to look into you know
what I wanted to do when I went into
college honestly going into college I
didn't really have a clear plan of where
I was gonna go after I got out of school
but that's that's definitely a big part
of what led me into engineering I got my
degree in electrical engineering at
Georgia Tech met some great people and
the door opened from there just at those
at that time period it was a great time
to be an engineering discipline I
remember we had we had to pick of the
litter and it came to interviews and
companies we got to meet with versus you
know not long after I was out of school
they went to a a lottery system where
you know and they selected you know some
number of people that actually got to
interview with with companies we went to
listen just pick the ones we wanted to
talk to and it was it was a great time
to you know to go after that so I don't
know you want to get into this yeah yeah
age or not well this is well this is
good I want to just take a quick a quick
moment to say that the amount of of
young people that we know that we're
exposed to tinkering at young ages and
like you said taking things apart
understanding how it works
putting things back trying to sometimes
put things back together know how it
works in the home and having a you know
mentors parents involved in and helping
with that process is so critical to a
lot of the engineers that we know today
so glad that that was one of your your
really powerful young moments yeah and
I'm honestly envious of kids today that
have you know all the robotics programs
and the technology that's out there to
play with today is pretty cool and yeah
that's part of what you know stepping
away hectic ofays you know we look at
the opportunity that we have as a
community to get people interested in
technology you know arts are important
too but you know today's problems
tomorrow's problems are completely you
know beyond complex and having solutions
to those problems is gonna take a bunch
of smart people that next generation
that are you know gonna be tackling
those yes yes so and they were we're
really fortunate to have like you were
saying like things like FIRST Robotics
are these really great engineering
simulation software's that were able to
now use to really enable the maximal
amounts of human creativity to to to
come into play and solve these
challenging problems that we're facing
so then how did how did the work and it
was Georgia - Georgia - Georgia Tech how
did how did you you know pick up you
know post Georgia Tech where you went
yeah so that was also by luck more than
design had a chance to interview with a
number of companies you know
in those days they did plant trips the
flight in a cross country you know to
all these great places
remember General Dynamics in in Texas
was building the f-16 first fly-by-wire
military jet at the time and so really
cool technology it happened to be about
a week before my interview with youlet
Packard they don't went to General
Dynamics and and that was a lot of
really neat people I love the people
there they're great planes were so cool
I would have loved to have been you know
I would have been an in-flight test
engineer but everyone I talked to was
bragging about these brand-new HP
automated test systems they're getting
right and and it's not good HP I know I
was familiar with them but this was like
the you know they were talking about
that more than they were you know the
job that General Dynamics and so I
interviewed with HP and really the
company is a great company to the people
you know that I got to work with great
start to a career did start out and a
Technical Sales and consulting and that
era I always always interested in
graphics I just love you know graphics
again if the stuff that's available
today I want to spend you know going
crazy about but back then you know we
had one graphics lab in school there
wasn't a general graphics curriculum in
school yet and I took advantage of you
know whatever I could but HP had some
really cool graphics you know on some of
the earlier desktop computers was it was
you know it was a lot of fun I just had
a real passion for it and that led me
into a part of HP that developed
engineering software and from that point
forward I was always plugged into that
that part of the business to avoid where
HP at one point had a product that was
called solid designers a 3d modeling
system the
they decided to split off as a separate
company that became co-create and I was
a part of that launch director of
marketing taking this you know entity
outs it from HP a very large company
into the time about a six hundred person
smaller company with this great line of
products and I got to do a lot more
things as a director of marketing and
that role that I've probably never done
in their career at HP I mean HP you have
great resources and you can depend on
you know this this breadth of talent you
know that is focused and PR content
development you know you're looking at
the marketing and all the parts of HP
this smaller company co-create we had to
do a lot of things you know yet every
one of us you know wore many hats and so
that was a great experience that
probably the foundation that that helped
me think about you know starting my own
company yes it was a good swing for you
from a how many thousands ten thousand
people the time of HP yeah it was it
time what HP was about forty thousand
this is what he wore those before they
bought EDS and some of the other
acquisitions down to what like ten
people or no no so the co creat was
about 600 people 600 600 600 okay yeah
that's still a massive yeah decreased
but that's still wearing a lot of hats
and so okay now now you know you were
explaining to this just about this a
little bit ago and I just want to hear
your perspective on it when you're when
you're there when you're joining your
hearing also many of the people talking
about HP's goods and then you're able to
be there at the time and this was what
what year was this 80 81 I you body yeah
oh you see 81 you're there this is
really the personal computing revolution
and so you're there and then you're also
really enjoying graphics as well at the
same time so tell us about just that
like the coolness of that time period
what you were learning in distributing
the personal computing out to business
and all this kind of stuff yeah so it
was pretty cool I mean literally in
college there was not a class it was a
standard class there was a special class
that you got to play with these
techtronic vector displays you know is
you know amazing how quickly the
technology you know evolved in my first
few years at HP but I remember you know
getting out of college I you know I got
a I got a car I got rid of my old
beat-up car after you know completing
college and that was a big step but I
remember putting in my car because we
got to take these computer systems home
with us you know they the more we played
with them the more we knew and you know
HP encouraged that and I remember at the
time my car was was worth maybe eight
thousand dollars and at the time the
graphics workstation which was you know
had a 12 inch display I mean this is you
know nothing by today's standards but it
was a color graphics workstation then ID
8:45 and you know at the time bit slice
processing and all of us now at the time
it's like this is amazing stuff the the
cost of that workstation was about
$80,000 and so I'm thinking it's like
okay so I've got an $8,000 car and I'm
I'm putting this $80,000 it's like it
was a little scary for you know yeah
young whippersnapper out of college you
know a little concerned just kind of
taking off of that much money in the
back of my car or something happened but
anyway yeah that that quickly evolved me
every year there were just amazing new
developments that that came out the
early cad stuff that that we were
working with HP work with you know a
number of software companies the the
earliest ones were actually mini
computer based with you know rs-232 you
know dumb terminals were the graphics
systems that that were you know
basically running that the CAD system
was back then and and then that evolved
you know within a few years and to you
know what we got to know today when you
know the more modern technology of
wireframe going into servers modeling
and then solid modeling and
and the compute resources were able to
actually deal with that but yeah you
know looking back on it uh you know
Moore's law and everything else to
compute power but just really that the
ability to model and create things in a
computer just again was this was a
passion I loved it why I stuck with it I
guess your story about taking the
$80,000 computer into a thousand dollar
car it's a big testament to like now
there's no computers that are more
expensive than the cars yeah it's so
yeah there may be one quantum computer
right but it's just crazy that that that
that's the Moore's law that's what's
happened in decreasing the amount of
costs increasing computational capacity
then okay so now that we're able to you
know leverage all this computational
capacity to take all these creative
ideas and model and build and that's
very exciting I want to know you know
these kind of things happen at the same
time smarts market and the volunteer
firefighting kind of happened
simultaneously how did those two things
well so I moved to Colorado with HP to
become a part of this group that was
creating you know these CAD solutions
and and then you know a few years after
that is when they decided let's split
off and create a separate company that
opened the door for our products to
actually be run on Silicon Graphics at
the time you know which is a big
competitor to HP would would not have
been you know possibility is we were
part of HP HP so us as a in a way to
sell more workstations and so it was
really cool step to you know really wait
just launched this new company called
co-create and and to be a part of that
and again great people I've been you
know fortunate blessed to have the
people in my life again more by luck
than design I think it just
was really lucky to have that part of it
I don't know things would be a lot
different if I people that influenced
and were part of my journey I had been
you know something different but movie
to Colorado I you know moved from you
know a the time I was living in an urban
environment in Atlanta Georgia and I've
had a lot of friends there but I loved
Colorado root when we go on business
trips to Colorado which is where HP at a
big plant
you know skiing obviously was a big
thing first time I went there in this
summertime is like holy cow the weather
is incredible you know just if you like
being outdoors it's it's just a great
place to be so I went from a very urban
environment you know to about working at
the one of the HP factories in Colorado
and then living in a very suburban
environment up in the hills essentially
people used to joke they say yeah you
know I don't know how you commute that
every day it's like a half hour drive
I'm thinking when I was in Atlanta I'd
have you know a 48 minute drive on a
good day and if traffic was bad it could
be you know two or three hours and so 30
minutes driving through the hills around
lakes and you know and you know it's
like it was therapeutic yes but where we
live is is also pretty remote and they
had a volunteer fire station there and
so I wasn't one I always like to you
know tinker and play with things and you
know curiosity led me add engineering I
wasn't one thinking I want to be a
fireman when I get older as a kid but
it's been a it was more a matter of
utility really to you know be
contributing in the environment that
we're in you know it's all volunteer and
it it's been actually an amazing
learning experiences you know a whole
different side of your brain were
wildland fire only we don't do is
structure so we don't go into burning
buildings which is fine with me
but the other thing which has been a lot
of fun and actually personally rewarding
is part of our training is also
emergency medicine so cool becoming an
EMT with yeah it's cool it's like going
back to I went back to college again you
know it was in my 40s and
I've got my EMT and and and just yeah I
mean that's the kind of thing where you
know literally you can save lives and
and and knowing that kind of stuff is
you know it's great just from a personal
perspective yes yes you know friends and
family you know yeah you never know when
and what you might need to you know
that's right yeah yeah it's it's cool
that there's the EMT training also comes
with the volunteer fire training this
transition to Colorado was actually a
major one then moved a huge huge and
then of course you're describing at the
same time how as you get more and more
into the school of the split four with
HP it was cocoa Creek co-create
co-create he'll create that kind of also
gave you a little bit of the
entrepreneurial roots that you wanted
for smart to market you know so teach us
about kind of that part Mel yeah so you
know getting my hands into a lot of
different aspects of marketing and
business you know they're the cocoa a
journey was part of it the other part
was just this continued like we're here
at Kofa is a connection with a very
tight community you know we you know you
go to events and meetings and you know
the the people the faces are the same
and name badges changed sometimes but it
was you know another part I think I
really enjoyed besides you know graphics
and and you know the engineering type
stuff the community that we have is just
amazing people and you know coming to
Coe Fez is over the years before it was
you know donated as a non-profit the
cortes Institute you know if you'll very
small when you come to this event as the
the brain trust that that is a part of
kotas is is inspiring it was always just
a great great event but the people that
I connected with in that journey with
co-create you know and the you know
editorial folks that are you know
writing stories about new technology and
developments the analysts that you know
are the thought leaders the partner
programs you know across hardware
platforms and and other software
companies
it was just a great ecosystem and I just
really enjoyed the people part of it too
and and I'm a people person so yeah
having that connection was was an
important part of my journey for sure
but those connections and knowledge you
know was the other part of it besides
the business learnings in launching this
company co-create you know getting the
connections and stuff and being able to
think about yeah you know could we do
more of things I really enjoy doing and
you know stepped outside of co-create
and went from you know HP 40,000 person
company to co-create a 600 ish person
company to a one-person company over the
years has gone to about 12 so nice it's
uh you know that's and it's still fun I
mean this is a big part of it
you know so teach us about smarts
markets offering so we're pretty broad
and are offering as far as what we do in
the in the marketing space were
delivering a very high level strategic
planning messaging branding type
solutions and consulting all the way
through I call it the grunt word of
marketing you know we're developing
websites white papers digital marketing
PR campaigns so we're you know unlike
just a consulting firm we actually do
you know execution of marketing some of
our clients we act as what we call as a
virtual director of marketing so we
bring a team you know that have all
these different disciplines that can you
know basically be a marketing department
at a much lower risk to you know a
client than having a staff and you
manage and fund you know not just the
direct cost but there's you know there's
the need to have the right people and
train and manage there's a lot of you
know to have an effective marketing team
there's a lot of cost and energy that
goes into that and we can kind of
deliver this as a you know as a service
as a package at the case for engineering
software or for more fields so our focus
are we very broad range of services but
yeah our focus
with few exceptions is your clients that
are in this engineering solution space
including hardware so we've worked with
you know big companies like HP and
Microsoft but their solution space in
the engineering focused areas na ec2
gotcha ok so all so all engineering
solutions you're helping them on that
this intelligent we figure out how to go
to market a websites sales all different
aspects of marketing this type of stuff
you know we say we say you know we help
our clients know reach and motivate
their target customers so who is your
customer you know and what do they look
like you know how do you make contact
with them and when you're in contact
with them how do you motivate them to
see what you do brings value and you
know ultimately get them to you know be
a customer and give us an example of an
engineering solution that you've worked
with that has gotten you've helped get
into the right hands of people so
actually one that kind of ties to this
area of that several years back was a
company called engineered intelligence
and they were a small company that
actually was one of the few that we work
with in Colorado most of our clients are
somewhere else in the US or the world
but engineer intelligence was a company
that had a really interesting solution
for high performance computing in
cluster computing they basically had a
virtualization of clusters so you could
have a machine that looks like a cluster
so people that are that developing for
parallel processing type applications
had a simple single way that they could
develop code for it was separated from
the actual Hardware environment and they
did very well they got the VC funded
moved to California here to the Bay Area
and then later were acquired and you
know as a part of the exit strategy but
that's you know one of many examples but
kind of cool you know started with a
very small organization they got you
know
funded they made the big move and you
know and
went on to other you know great things
so and then P what would you say have
been some of the as you've been doing
this for what is it 18 18 years now
crazy with engineering solutions what
have been some of the trends that
engineering solutions are moving towards
well clearly you know today cloud and
it's it's interesting and talking with
Mac Eleni with on shape of course they
have a really cool cloud solution for
design and engineering and it wasn't
that long ago if you were to talk to
companies and organizations and
individuals especially engineers you
know the idea of you know not having
your data on your you know workstation
and and you know keeping the control of
it that was you know it's a serious
cultural you know you know the
conversation 10 years ago you know if
all the technology were there to do what
it could do today the mindsets were you
know very opposed to you know putting
data out in the cloud and so there's a
generational thing going on now
obviously technologies move where you
know we have you know personal devices
that have access to compute power that's
just beyond you know we might have
imagined you know 10 20 years ago and of
course that's driving a lot of change
and you know in our space here in the
engineering software space you know
everybody is either there or moving to
there with some part of their solution
if not all of the solution you know in
the cloud so that's clearly a platform
enabler that it's making some big
changes you know the other things that
I've seen that are exciting just over
the years it is the you know usability
of solutions and so Joe walls for the
assess of project that he's leading it's
looking at how you know simulation is
not for just the analysts that you know
know how to create a finite element
model but really bringing that kind of
capability to the masses yes and Sela
works one of our clients has got some
really cool things with their simulation
products were a designer you know has a
great toolkit
that not that long ago you know your
general engineer designer would probably
not be able to you know use those kinds
of functions effectively and confidently
that's the other thing is you know
having some confidence and the results
that you get at the end of the process
yeah this these solutions that you're
listing right now are art you know
democratizing the ones ability to do
generative design or to do simulate
engineering simulations taking that and
giving it to the hands of kids or or
young adults adolescents and-and-and in
collegiate students and then having
their creative potential roll off with
it is such a crucial part of this also
yeah all of the all the way you were
saying with with algorithms that are now
running our computations in the cloud
it's a very it's a much crazier thing
than what we thought was just gonna be
happening locally how do we know our
data secure all these types of questions
arise from these questions from these
from these new processes so now okay so
now you're you're following you're
following these engineering solutions as
they're as they're building up and
you're you're providing them with you
know really powerful marketing marketing
waste of ways to market in this sort of
you know this two and a half years now
board of directors cough ESCO fezzes you
know aggregating this deceive this
beautiful community of leaders in the
engineer software community what is what
is you know you gave some examples of
what joe walsh doing assess initiative
and we were just talking about some
other ones where is this where is this
converging where is this converging and
going towards you know the rocket
ization all these other things but where
do you really where do you feel that the
essence of this is moving us in the
direction towards you mean you're
talking about Kofi's or you're talking
about the industry co fez plus what the
co phase is able to highlight from
industry yeah yeah yeah so you know Co
Fez now as a non-profit under the koba's
Institute is you know it's important
that we look at you know our ability to
encompass more than just you know the
CAD software space and and
and that's clearly where Co Fez began
and the AEC and the project development
CAD software space the challenges that
are you know pasted by people developing
products or buildings today are getting
more and more complex obviously yes and
so the kinds of things that Co Fez can
do as a community and the people that
come together whether they analyst
thought leader types the people that are
developing you know the actual
engineering software the visionary users
the editors that are writing about it
the VCS that are you know funding you
know the next great thing they all come
together to Co Fez and and so the
conversations that happen here you know
clearly go well beyond CAD it's it's
this is what the convergence scene was
about this year is is you know augmented
reality virtual reality machine learning
and AI autonomous vehicles IOT all these
elements of different parts of
technology have created brand new
opportunities that you know we're you
know not there you know not that long
ago that when you're developing a
product or a building and by the way I
see those lines blurry know what we know
this is ATC or is it project development
where there's you know there's smart
buildings yeah there's tons of
mechanical and product innovations that
go into buildings beyond just the
architectural design and so there's just
yeah there's a culmination of this
convergence across all aspects of what
we're talking about so from the
Institute Copas institute perspective we
want to you know make sure that we're
casting a broader net that incorporates
all that takes advantage of this brain
trust it comes to Co Fez and and really
get discussions going around you know
what is truly the future of engineering
software that no needs to be addressing
these challenges and you know take
advantage of the new opportunities that
are there with you know all of things
like IOT I mean who would have thought
you know 10 years ago the things that
are connected that are connected today
you know thinking ahead five years from
now the numbers uh word that were shared
of how many devices will be connected
you know just is like just beyond the
number of people in the world so it's
it's pretty amazing and it's just I know
it's exciting ride to be on it's a true
the we understand the biological
perception evolution now we have a
robotic perception evolution happening
this is nuts it's Co fesses brain trust
is one of the most fascinating yet I
really highly recommend checking out Co
fezzes links below
last question P what would be a really
important skill for kids and adults to
learn in the 21st century uh
communication you know technology is
great but where I've seen you know the
most successful enterprises is really
you know having you know that technology
savvy of being able to communicate you
know and and and being human beings you
know at the end of the day you know I'm
drawn to technology as much as anyone
you know you're you know pushing the
buttons all the time but uh but don't
forget we're human beings and that
interaction that like Co Fez is a
perfect example when you get people
together and the conversations happen
not that you can't communicate in other
vehicles but I certainly hope we never
lose that face-to-face you know human
being interaction that that I think
really does help us break through
barriers and become more innovative and
solve bigger problems yeah yeah well
said thank you so much for coming onto
the show and teaching us well thank you
for you know what you do thank you
yeah we have so many brilliant people to
continue highlighting we really
appreciate everyone for tuning in thank
you so much check out Pete's links below
check out the links to Co Fez as well
support the artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in support Co fest
support simulation our links are below
also go and build the future everyone
share this type of content with more
people get inspired manifest your dreams
into the world huge thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon peace